début de journée aussi à celle des pour
la docteure boulanger accueillis par
sani carole varela perez madame père est
originaire du paraguay fait partie d'une
brigade de contrôle des infections
composé entièrement des migrants formé
en médecine dans leur pays d'origine
qu'on a regardé dans je contribue et
pendant on s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait là des médecins étrangers qui
étaient pas qu'ils avaient pas encore le
droit de pratiquer ici et qui faisait
autre chose mais qui voulez contribuer
une trentaine de ces immigrants
composent la brigade formée fin avril
leur mission
enseigner les notions d'hygiène pour
éviter d'autres éclosions dans les
résidences et ch et c'est l'idée c'est
quand même des personnes qui ont des
notions de prévention et contrôle des
infections et en un certain qu'ils sont
qui ont fait bien combattu les bolonais
au congo pour dire quelque chose
la brigade et réunit périodiquement pour
mettre à jour les connaissances sur le
virus
des gens comme soeur monique qui se
retrouver coincé à montréal au début de
la pandémie
j'y arrivais pour voir ma famille qui
vient de commencer j'ai pas été capable
de partir et je me suis inscrite sur le
site j'ai contribué ou encore diane qui
était médecin au burkina faso
déjà la satisfaction morale d'être utile
à sa société parce que ça comme j'ai dit
ça fait quatre ans que je suis là donc
je me sens parties prenantes de la
société et donc je me sens utile pour
tous ici un engagement qui découle de
leur première vocation la médecine on
était dans une petite frustration d'être
de professionnels de la santé ne pas
pouvoir participer à ça et puis là la
dsp nous a offert cette opportunité
puis voilà donc l'année agent de
prévention
les médecins québécois qui travaillent
avec eux apprécient le rapport permet de
faire la bonne technique
quand on met les équipements quand on
les enlève puisque ça permet de prévenir
de se contaminer nous-mêmes pour moi
c'est c'est une belle chose que j'espère
qu'on va à la fin de cette crise la
reconnaître la force de ses médecins
étrangers là pour leur donner le rôle
qu'ils ont à jouer dans notre société
d'ici la fin de la pandémie on pourrait
élargir le rôle de cette brigade formée
d'ange gardien venu d'ailleurs ici david
gêne-t-il et radio canada montréal